it's et's social study what the stars
are posting online young hip and
carefree paris Jackson stuns in a sunny
beach snap that red stick your toes in
the sand JLo has a family picnic with
her twins Max and Emme after news broke
that she's dating Alex Rodriguez the
singer rocked a floral cutout dress to
dine outdoors with her kids they love it
they love it another mom of two soaking
up the Sun Jessica Simpson shows off her
toned legs in a pair of denim daisy
dukes it's amazing we happen to do this
together moving on Orlando Bloom spends
quality time with he and ex miranda
kerr's son flynn following his split
from katy perry the proud dad shared a
pic at an amusement park while riding a
roller coaster Orlando captioned the pic
quote a six-year-old will remind you of
all the important things in life mo esta
su running in the Bupa chill then
there's makeup free Adele striking a
pose with Elmo in New York City after he
made a plea to sing with her and check
out Kelly Osbourne throwing it way back
to 10 years ago with the dell she posted
a pic of the then 18 year old singer
co-hosting a British radio oven with
Osbourne
you